- Welcome back, everybody.
We're here with Martha
Stewart! Give it up!
(audience cheers and applauds)
Our next guest is simply
one of the greatest
basketball players of all time.
I'm gonna hope I get this right.
She is a seven-time WNBA All-Star,
a three-time WNBA Champion,
including a championship this year,
and a two-time (laughs) WNBA MVP.
So she is really good at
basketball. (chuckles)
(crowd chuckles)
- [Martha] Wow.
- Her new ESPN documentary is called
"Candace Parker: Unapologetic."
You can see it on ESPN and ESPN+.
Everybody, give it up for Candace Parker!
(audience cheers and applauds)
(upbeat music)
- [Kelly] Come on over!
(audience cheers)
Oh my gosh.
- The height?
All right, back to back?
Can we back to back it?
- And I'm in really big heels!
It's fine. It's fine.
It's beautiful! You can reach
everything on the shelves.
Have y'all ever met?
- I have not!
- No, but I'm a big fan.
- I am a big fan of yours!
- Thank you, thank you.
- I have a number of your
books, and my mom is--
- [Kelly] There's a hundred to pick from!
- Fans of both of you all.
- So, explain the documentary.
Why was this important for you?
- I think it was so
important just at that point,
in this point in my life,
just to show how far
I've come in my career,
but also with my family.
So coming off a successful rookie season,
I had my daughter my second year.
And that was the first question,
was "What about your career?"
And then when I'd be on the road,
people would always ask me,
"Who's taking care of your daughter?"
- Oh my God. Do you ask men that?
- And that would be the thing.
I'm like, "Do you ask
LeBron where his kids are?"
- No, you don't, because
you call that babysitting.
And I'm done.
- Exactly. Exactly.
- Yeah.
- That's how it is.
- It drives me nuts.
- So I just noticed
the difference.
- Yeah.
- And you can follow your dreams
and still bring your family along.
- Absolutely.
(audience applauds)
You know, I find it more powerful,
I find it more powerful that
you had all that weight on you,
everybody was like,
"Oh my God, she's going to be the face,"
and then you did do something
that was very much a feminine thing to do.
We have babies. Ha-ha.
And it's a beautiful thing.
What sucks for you, and
I just want to apologize
for humans that are mean,
is that that should have been
a beautiful time for you.
That should have been a
beautiful moment for you,
to be pregnant,
'cause you always wanted
to have a kid, right?
- Always.
- Yeah.
- From a young age, I was playing house.
I had four kids, all my names picked out
for my kids before--
- We were so different.
(everyone laughs)
- I wanted to--
- What are the names?
- Well, my daughter's name is Lailaa
and my son's name is Airr.
But at the time, you know, those change,
'cause you get a partner and
they have an opinion too,
and you have to kinda
compromise and all that.
- And you're like, "Oh my
God, I guess yours is better."
- "Yeah, and I guess you
get to name them, too."
But I always wanted to be
a mom, and you're right,
and I think this time around,
when my wife and I were expecting,
it was like I wanted to be able
to post pictures of her pregnant.
I wanted to be able to share
the joy.
- I'm glad
you celebrated that though.
It empowers other people to be able
to balance both if they'd like.
- And to be able to balance and not worry
about what the perception is,
and not doing it because of others.
You do it for yourself.
And so I think that's the
biggest thing with motherhood,
is it's taught me to continue to strive
to what makes me happy and
what makes my family happy.
- Yeah!
And it's so interesting,
too, when they say,
"Oh, who's watching your child?"
I'm like, "Who is watching
any person's child
that has a job?"
You know what I'm saying?
Grandma, a nanny, somebody.
- That's true. That's true.
(audience applauds)
- Well, we have all dealt with divorce,
which is horrific.
What's it like for
y'all in the public eye?
Mine was very public.
That's very hard.
'Cause I know a lot of
people deal with divorce,
even at work, and it's
like, you have to show up,
you have to smile, you
have to do your job,
but you're kinda dying inside.
How is that for y'all?
- Eh. (chuckles)
(audience laughs)
- No one wants this therapy session
right now.
- I was just like,
yeah, yeah.
- I got divorced during
my wedding book tour.
- Oh my God!
- And I had to talk about weddings
and wedding dresses and
how to have a wedding.
- What?
- And that's when I had
to get divorced.
- Oh my
goodness.
- It was horrible.
- You just trumped both of us!
- Right?
You win.
- Oh my God! That must have been so hard!
- And it took a long time. Dragged out.
Don't drag it out.
That's my advice.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Don't drag it out.
- Wow.
- Well, you try not to, yeah.
- That's a hard follow.
- Yeah, I feel like my life,
I'm either killing it
in the business world,
like with my purpose and my job, my love,
or I'm killing it in romance.
And it's very hard to have
both for me, apparently.
But how do you feel?
Did you feel like it was a struggle?
'Cause your life has changed.
You were with a man,
now you're with a woman.
You got to tell this whole story.
Your life has changed dramatically.
That's hard to do in general,
but also in the public eye,
that's a lotta eyes watching.
- And I think sometimes, you know,
in the documentary I talk about
how it took a long time for me to be okay
with my journey and myself,
and the understanding
that not everybody is going to love it,
but I just ask that you respect it.
And so, with that being said--
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- And I think you're a better mom
because you're pursuing
your goals and your dreams,
and I know I'm a better mom
because I'm pursuing my dreams.
- I tell my daughter that.
- Yes!
- My daughter will be like,
"Why can't you come to this?
Somebody else's mom comes to this."
I'm like, "Okay, well, I have a job,
and I just want you to look at me
and know that when you
grow up and you have a job,
you can also have kids, too,
and you can also make it all happen."
- And you can balance,
and you wanna be there,
and there are things
that you have to miss.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But--
- And there are things
my mother missed.
I'm fine.
- You're okay.
- You grew up okay.
- I'm like,
"Everybody's gonna make everything?"
No, you don't.
People miss games,
people miss performances.
That's okay.
- A hundred percent.
- You try your best, but that's okay.
I hate when people are like,
"Oh, you missed that one?"
I'm like, "I made the other 10!"
I was like, you know?
- Listen, I am not the cupcake mom.
You know, the one
that does all the cupcakes?
- I don't bake.
- Have you seen the viral thing now
with the lunches where they
cut dinosaurs into eggs
and all that stuff?
- Yeah.
- No, my daughter got lucky
if the sandwich was together.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- But she's good. You know?
- [Kelly] Everybody's different.
- It's the thought that counts, right?
- Yeah, you were, yeah.
I was like, she probably did
do cookie cutter dinosaurs.
- Yeah, she did dinosaur.
You did the shapes cut out. (laughs)
(audience applauds)
- She's, like, "Well, I kinda kill
with that too."
- She goes "I'm outta this."
- Oh my God.
Did you ever feel that you had to pick
between love and work?
- I didn't buy the pony.
- [Kelly] I didn't buy the pony! (laughs)
- And that keeps haunting me.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- Get the pony? Okay. (laughs)
- Oh my god. Oh my god.
- I hope my daughter's not watching this.
Christmas is coming up.
Oh my gosh.
- She's like,
"Martha said that you
were gonna get me a pony."
(audience applauds)
Martha made history
with her Sports Illustrated
Swimsuit issue cover
at 81 years old.
(audience cheers)
- First of all, ma'am.
- [Candace] Goodness.
- Every 81-year-old out there
is like, "This is not like the others."
Why now? This is incredible.
- I wonder.
They never asked me before.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I would've done it when I was 40.
I looked great at 40.
(audience applauds)
(Kelly laughs)
- Well, they think you
look great at 81 too.
So it's just, I love
that you you did it too.
I think it was the most
popular one, right?
Of the covers?
- Yeah. Yeah.
We got like many, many
billions of impressions.
- It was crazy.
(audience applauds)
I do think though, you age really well.
So I don't know if that's
comparable to the rest of us.
But I don't know, did
your mother influence you?
Didn't she kind of influence your attitude
about aging?
- Oh, mom was great.
Mom was beautiful and with it
and totally alert and intelligent.
And she raised six kids.
- No.
- And she was great until the
day she passed away at 93.
- [Kelly] 93?
- And she never sick.
And she was fantastic. She
was swimming every day.
You know, she's an amazing woman.
- What a great role model as well.
- Very, very good role model.
- Well you are following in
those footsteps, aren't ya?
I was like wow!
So I don't know, do
you feel like with age,
like people get put in boxes,
whether it's in the industry,
I'm sure they do as well in sports.
Like do you feel that?
- I feel like to some extent,
the world likes putting
women, especially in boxes.
And then getting mad when
they don't fit in the box
that they put 'em in.
And I think the limitations
that they put on you
and what you're capable
of, I'm six foot four,
and when I was younger,
I didn't wanna play.
- You're short.
- I'm short.
- I know.
- That's what I thought.
That's why I wanted to play point guard.
And everybody was like, no,
you have to stand by the basket
and you know, shoot hooks and do all that.
And for me it was like, I
really loved Alan Iverson.
He was my favorite player growing up.
- Yeah.
- Right?
And my dad was like, "Go
dribble. Like go pass."
And I think now we're seeing
the value of being versatile
and playing different positions.
But yeah, of course the world
puts limitations on you.
And I think it's just your job
to kind of be like whatever, right?
- No. Yeah, say no thank you.
- [Candace] You're like nah.
- Nah. Just an N-A-H.
So why have you chosen against retiring?
You said you were gonna retire, right?
- Well, first--
- [Kelly] Or somebody else said.
- I've been pondering
retirement from basketball
at like 34, 35, 36, 37.
- How old are you?
- I'm 37 right now.
- Oh my gosh.
- Still pondering.
Pondering retirement.
But what's crazy is now
my teammates are closer
to my daughter's age than my age.
So they're over there doing TikToks,
and I'm like, what are y'all doing?
Like how do you know all of these dances
and these dance moves?
And I'm like, grandma on the team.
That's like, wait, what's
the lyric to that song?
You're singing what?
Like, that's me in the locker room.
So, I'm--
- And you're only 37.
- But it's coming.
'Cause when I started
realizing we were closer--
- Tic Tac don't, or tic-tac-toe,
whatever it's called.
- See? See, exactly.
- TikTok don't matter,
it's how you play on the,
yeah, it's how you play on the court.
That's what matters.
- That's true.
But when you start
seeing that you daughter
is having more in common with
your teammates than you are,
you're like, "Wow,
this is real life."
- Is your daughter gonna play?
- She plays volleyball and basketball.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah.
- And she loves, yeah,
she loves basketball.
- I didn't know this,
but some WNBA players,
they have to get second
jobs because the pay.
Is that still like happening?
- A hundred percent.
For the first 10 years of my career,
I went from April to October in the WNBA
and from October to April overseas.
So I played in Russia, I played in Turkey,
I played two years in China.
And my daughter was a five month old baby,
packed her up, 12 bags, went to Russia.
That was what, and still is, the reality
of a lot of WNBA players.
And you know, I think it's
just important to understand
that like when that, you know,
corporations, organizations,
they put women on
television, women's sports,
I mean now everybody's catching up.
But it's been a thing.
It's just that the
visibility wasn't there.
And so now I think the more visibility
that women's sports has,
the more sponsorship,
equal pay.
- More equality, right.
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
- It's gonna happen.
- Yeah 'cause that's insane,
the difference between men and women.
We need a commercial break, everybody.
(audience applauds)
Check out "The World of Martha" on Amazon
for all your holiday entertaining needs,
as well as the best in kitchen and dining,
bedding and bath, and
furniture and home decor,
everything under the umbrella.
And don't miss "Candace
Parker: Unapologetic"
on ESPN and ESPN+.